well we begin this morning with breaking  news from Southern California at least  one person is dead and three others were  injured including the gunman following a  shooting at Costco at costco there  witnesses say the gunfire started when  two men got into an argument the  shooting late last night was at a store  in the city of Corona about 50 miles  east of Los Angeles witnesses said they  heard at least six shots terrified  customers and workers stampeded for the  exits others ducked for cover this  worker says people were looking after  one another especially women and  children pretty much you saw any any  kids or women everyone were just kind of  grabbing them and making sure they were  they were okay first before anything  else employees were looking after each  other making sure we kind of got a  silent headcount as we're running out as  best as we can the gunman was taken into  custody and hospitalized police have not  identified